[Music]
[Applause]
good morning Hank it's Tuesday May 5th
2020 your 40th birthday and this Hank
this is the all-star cinema jig which
has been my white whale these last 15
months as I hunted it across the globe
hoping to celebrate your birthday by
uniting my great love of cinema jigs and
your great love of the Smash Mouth song
all-star now this isn't your only
all-star belated present but let's begin
here with this extremely limited edition
toy a nerdfighter in Tokyo named Rebecca
with help from her partner ocean figured
out that these had been for sale in
Japan at Costco's like eleven years ago
and she found one and she shipped it to
me and brought my quest to an end
tangentially related rebecca has an
instagram art project about traffic
cones called cone life and it is
beautiful and I love nerdfighteria link
in the doobly-doo but that's not all
also some people from the discord
channel 2 at Aria got together and took
a regular cinema jig and hacked it and
now it sings all-star in one mode and in
a different mode contains an audio
birthday card for you
and the nerdfighter subreddit got
together and created a version of
all-star using only clips from our
videos here's a bit of that
well that would your start coming and
they don't stop coming and vegetable if
I hid from the ground Flemington make
sense not to live for fun your brain
gets smart but your head dumb so much to
do taking the back streets also there's
more a musician and singer music
specialist named Aaron made you a proper
all-star cinema jig symphony so Hank
here is all-star but it's every singer
magic
[Applause]
[Music]
full versions of all this stuff by the
way in the doobly-doo below hanky did
the creators behind these projects ask
that I donate to charity instead of
paying them so in addition to bringing
much singing magic joy into the world
this silliness has raised money to help
refugees and support food banks and
other causes also one last thing Hank
dftba.com is releasing a t-shirt in
honor of your birthday
it's nun pizza with left Hank and it is
available only at dftba.com and only for
the next few days all the proceeds will
go to charity oh my god nun pizza with
left Hank really is the light that I
have needed in these dark times Hank
happy 40th birthday despite the
circumstances I'll see you on Friday
it's gonna say goodbye in a second here